what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we're gonna be dangerous here
and we are going to make a video about
ultra instinct Goku vs. Herald of
Galactus Hulk's so I feel like we got to
break these characters down right like
look at these characters for what they
are so we're we're gonna kick things off
with Goku so Goku I don't really watch
Dragonball I always started with Dragon
Ball Z but Goku throughout Dragon Ball Z
his fighting style always follow a
pattern when it comes to Goku in a
battle it always ends in one of two ways
but when the fight starts let's take for
example the character of Raddatz the
fight will start with rabbits and goku
will say okay how powerful is this guy
in relation to me and goku will face-off
against him and in the middle of this
fight they'll stop the middle discover
will stop goku will rest for a second
and say okay here's what I learned about
this guy
then Goku will jump back into the
conflict again as Goku jumps back into
the conflict they'll rest again and Goku
will say okay here's what else I've
learned about that guy and it'll keep
going that way and going that way until
one of two things happens either Goku
realizes he has the power to defeat that
opponent uses everything he learned and
then defeats them or Goku realizes he
does not have the power to defeat that
opponent and then he basically gets aid
from some external source in the case of
Raddatz it was Goku basically you know
it was piccolo blasting Raddatz you know
where this special beam cannon or
whatever it is elemental what the actual
Japanese name is but it's piccolo
blasting Raddatz Goku basically has a
hole blown in them in the process
because he's holding Raddatz aiming Goku
just moves on to the crossroads now when
goku goes on to these crossroads he
comes to a fork in the road the fork in
the road is either you can go on to the
afterlife or you can go train and
because goku says i'm a protector of the
earth i'm gonna go train because i faced
off against aratus and Raddatz had a
level of power that i just wasn't ready
for so I want to be equal to rabbits or
more powerful so that if a foe that's
equal to Raddatz or more powerful comes
to earth I'll be ready for them this
continues on with the arrival of nappa
and Vegeta Goku eventually comes back
goku jumps into a fight against vegeta
and the cycle continues in the exact
same fashion goku fights vegeta they
back off goku says here's what i've
learned they jump into the fight again
until goku comes to the realization
either i have enough power to defeat
vegeta or I do not this led directly
into the defeat of vegeta more or less
where he was just took off in his a
little shift yoku recovers in a hospital
Bulma and everybody learns about the
Dragon Balls on Amick they chart a
mission Goku follows after them after
realizing everything that's going on his
ship goes awry his gravity wall goes
nuts and he's basically training and
enhanced
gravity now that's kind of a lucky break
but that's how the story goes when
you're the star of the show
Goku arrives on Namek things pop off but
he's far more powerful than he was when
he was on earth this goes into his
escapades with captain ginyu and so on
and so forth and then finally we get the
fight between Goku and Frieza the
pattern follows the exact same standard
Goku jumps into a fight with Frieza Goku
says here's what I've learned him and
Frieza fight again
Goku stops here's what I've learned and
then Goku follows into the crossroads
again either I have enough power to
defeat Frieza or I don't have enough
power to defeat Frieza
it led to him realizing he doesn't have
the power to pull it off on his own he
creates the giant spear bomb and then it
still doesn't work and that's where
things begin to change and that's where
ultra instinct or at least the concept
of ultra instinct begins to play this
sort of role in the sense that Goku
basically taps into a level of power
that he never had before he becomes a
Super Saiyan he basically wrecks fries
at least Frieza to dynamic and then
takes off and then that's where the
whole learning process of Goku begins to
come in after every single fight that
Goku has every single conflict that he
gets into whether he lives or dies his
idea is what did I learn from this what
information did I pull out of this in
the fight with Frieza he learned two
things one Frieza was insanely powerful
but Frieza was also a foe that cannot be
reasoned with that cannot be
rationalized with he experienced that
with you know with really with you know
King Piccolo back in the day and he
experienced that with Raddatz but Frieza
was of such a level of power that if
Frieza had been allowed to run unchecked
then it would have led to all manner of
terrible things happening and probably
the destruction of the earth the second
half of this idea was the Goku sat down
and said I became a Super Saiyan during
that fight but while my my my power was
basically fed by my constant rage over
what might happen if freezes not
defeated over the death of Crillon and
all these different things of lives of
Frieza had taken over the course of his
existence
Goku sat down and said but what would
happen if I'm not upset what would
happen if somebody just shows up on
earth and I'm in the middle of taking a
bath and I'm calm and I need to become a
Super Saiyan and that's when it would
have basically dawned on him if he
becomes a Super Saiyan it saps a massive
amount of his power and so the first
step to being able to master that is to
just stay a Super Saiyan all the time
this combined with all the other things
that he did led to you know massive
expanses of his power and then everybody
else began to learn the same thing that
you'd have figured that out as well when
he became a Super Saiyan but that's the
nature of Goku but if you look at every
single battle he ever fights whether
it's him training with a son Gohan
with sell the fight with majin buu it's
always the same thing
goku jumps into a conflict goku analyzes
what he's learned goku jumps back into
the conflict and then goku may or may
not have the power to defeat that person
and does whatever he has to do to win
ultra instinct takes that entire concept
and turns it on its head and all the
power that he's gained over the years
Super Saiyan 1 Super Saiyan 2 Super
Saiyan 3 the Super Saiyan blue form all
those different powers that he has it's
a linear progression he faces an enemy
he gets stronger he faces an enemy he
gets stronger and while he is a great
fighter it's all predicated on him
studying a fighter
in the interim between them fighting
ultra instinct removes all that ultra
instinct basically comes along and it
says under normal circumstances Goku is
fighting against an opponent and he has
to analyze their attack so he can
counter them while simultaneously
studying his opponent as they fight but
ultra instinct removing that basically
says he just counter-attacks
instinctively and so instead of having
to split his thought process between the
attacks of the opponent as well as how
their bodies fare and he can focus
exclusively on that opponent that's the
difference that's the massive difference
here is while it seems subtle on the
surface it's huge allow me a little bit
of this kind of kind of break away for a
second one of the greatest NFL running
backs of all time was a guy named Barry
Sanders why because Barry Sanders was
interviewed and Barry Sanders basically
said the reason why it's like you know
trying to catch him it's like catching
smoke is because when there's going to
be a play where he's going to run the
ball before the play even starts he's
looking at all these guys on the on the
defensive line and he's looking at where
the break will most likely be so he
knows how to get to that defensive line
if a couple of those guys tackle him
before they even realized that he's gone
he already knows the tag was broke he's
like look these guys never had me in the
first place and so while they're still
trying to tackle him he's looking to the
next guy and the guy after that and the
guy after that and he knows the route he
needs to run in order to get to the end
zone he can you know adjust his
movements he can kind of change things
up on a fly and sure he gets tackled
nobody's perfect but it's instinctual
it's an ingrained part of who he is and
that's the nature of ultra instinct if
Goku can face off against an opponent
and instinctively counter their attacks
then he doesn't have to sweat his
mindset between what their attacks are
and how they're faring he can focus
exclusively on that opponent in terms of
how they're feeling are they getting
frustrated is he basically pushing them
to the point where their power is
beginning to decrease he can focus on
nuances that he would
normally be able to detect things that
can give him a far grander picture of
what that opponents capable of now ultra
instinct was a fleeting thing it was
basically a moment in the show that
allowed him to go toe-to-toe with jiren
for a brief amount of time but it
basically says we're go cruise follow
this linear progression on how it is
that he's got stronger and stronger over
the years and how he fights it blows the
doors off everything and says actually
if he masters this there's no limit to
what it is that he can achieve or what
opponent he can fight it's kind of like
this perfect harmony between mind and
body in his fighting style something
that he's always you know always focused
on but this brings into sharp relief the
idea of the Incredible Hulk The
Incredible Hulk is just a mindless rage
machine 99% of the time that we see him
there are two instances where this is
not the case really three if we think
about it the first is Professor Hulk
which is kind of this perfect
combination of green Hulk and gray Hulk
but the two most prominent versions of
the Incredible Hulk
our world breaker hulk and maestro hulk
now rule breaker Hulka is smart for the
most part but he's not strategically
smart like maestro Tokyo's Markstrom
Hulk is more of a warlord than anything
else but we're not talking about him
we're talking about World War Hulk what
where Hulk is the higher echelon of what
the Incredible Hulk is capable of part
of the monster Hulk I think is a little
bit stronger but world war hulk is still
a pretty formidable being so much so
that no one on earth except for the
century probably the most powerful being
on earth in terms of sheer strength and
durability was able to face off against
world war hulk and it led to a
standstill now when it comes to like
Herald of Galactus Hulk this was
basically a story where the hall became
a Herald of Galactus we don't really
know what he's capable of we can kind of
grab other characters who have been
Herald Silver Surfer Frankie Rey we can
grab these different heralds and we can
say okay here's what they were capable
of but the long and short of it is that
when a person becomes a Herald of
Galactus their power is amplified and
more often than not the power they get
through Galactus is designed to
complement whatever power they already
have and so in the case of like Silver
Surfer he's kind of an exception because
he was just a regular guy but because he
was so keen on exploring he was given
the tools that he would need to explore
the universe as well as ensure Galactus
would be able to locate plan as he
needed to sustain his own life energies
but Silver Surfer at his peak was
capable of things like time travel he
had strengths that rivaled the
Incredible Hulk for a time he could work
reality on a minor scale there are a lot
of things that he could do but the
Incredible Hulk is a being of just
infinite strength and so we
have to believe that whatever abilities
he got from Galactus would be designed
to amplify that strength to basically
say instead of his base level strength
being down here his base level strength
is now up here so in his normal form
he's equal to a world breaker Hulk
capable of shattering planets when he's
amped up he's just that much stronger so
the question becomes how would you take
a person who had his base form can
obliterate planets at his you know amped
up form could do god knows what and then
turn around and have them face off
against ultra instinct Goku my money is
on ultra instinct Goku that I would
really just kind of have to give it to
him because power cosmic would allow
Hulk to do a lot of different things but
if it complements his existing abilities
then he's just gonna be really really
really really strong but he's not a
thinking machine he doesn't have the
ability to counter attack a person
without thinking about it Goku does that
and so we're ultra instinct Goku could
counter every single attack that the
Herald of Galactus Hulk dishes out while
at the same time he'd be able to
basically analyze whether or not bulk is
getting stronger getting weaker whatever
the case may be basically break down his
body in terms of what it is that he's
doing and then counter even more
effectively now if we say ultra instinct
lasts for like an indefinite amount of
time the Goku's years and years in the
future sure that would be the case if
it's like we've seen in this fight
against durin that is basically just
this brief moment then like Goku would
inevitably lose most likely but even
then there's no guarantee because you
know Super Saiyan blue Goku is God level
powerful I mean it's crazy how powerful
he is and we would maybe argue that with
Hulk fighting long enough that he would
probably be able to stand toe-to-toe
against Super Saiyan blue though kook
but most likely not
it's the Superman effect well who would
win Superman to the Incredible Hulk well
right off the bat Incredible Hulk would
lose but if the fight goes on long
enough
The Incredible Hulk would win because
this drink has no limit Superman has a
limited amount of strength so again it's
kind of weird in terms of how that
unfolds but that's just taking the power
cosmic and applying it to the Incredible
Hulk in terms of physical strength if we
in turn were to say that the Incredible
Hulk as The Herald of Galactus has all
the powers that Silver Surfer has well
then suddenly ultra instant Goku loses
hands-down no questions asked because
now we're not just introducing
heightened levels of strength we're
introducing all these different elements
that Goku would most likely not be able
to counter against so I mean when it
comes to like reality warping it's hard
to gauge that because in Dragonball you
don't really see much reality warping
you don't really see a person come along
and turn like a candle into a fox
all the
Stream levels of power that you see are
done for a couple different things to
create energy projections maybe create
Holograms or false duplicates you know
you see them like destroying universes
or planets or different things like that
but by and large its confined a physical
strength all the power they have
translates into how hard can they hit
how fast can they move how much energy
can they shoot if someone like you know
Herald of Galactus Hulk has all the
powers of the Silver Surfer then it
becomes a reality warping game can goku
with ultra instinct counterattack The
Incredible Hulk
turning him into a rock and throwing him
to the other side of the universe
that's where things begin to get crazy
and that's where you basically have
questions if there's no answers - so I
don't I don't have an answer to that if
we're talking about sheer strength just
pure strength a fist to fist fight
between ultra instinct Goku and Herald
of Galactus hawk then ultra instinct
though who wins hands down just because
of the fact that he be able to counter
everything the Hulk is doing possibly
even before the Incredible Hulk knew
that he was gonna do just because of the
fact that the Incredible Hulk is not a
thinking machine he's just a fighting
machine but if we're talking about
enhanced levels of strength cosmic
awareness the abilities of the Silver
Surfer reality-warping all those godly
abilities that traditionally come with
the power cosmic
then Herald of Galactus Hulk wins hands
down because his abilities they allow
him to do almost anything they Goku
wouldn't be able to counter-attack just
because it'd be it'd be so extreme but
I'm kind of curious what you guys think
I mean I'm waiting on the debunking
videos surely somebody's gonna come
along and just be like actually nope I'm
gonna power scale and you know I'm gonna
pick the books to make sure that you
know like Hulk wins I have no idea but
let me know what you guys think cuz I'm
kind of curious about this again totally
care about confirming opinions I mean if
you were rooting for Goku and in this
video you know agree with you that's
awesome
wasn't really what I was shooting for
just kind of my idea on who it is that I
think would end up winning this but let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section but if you guys are new
here to come as explained make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later please
[Music]